Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Okay, ich schränke das ein. Tintenstrahltrucker sind echt die dümmste Erfindung der Menschheit.
Jedes Mal. Und noch schlimmer, noch noch schlimmer Leute.
Multifunktions-Tintenstrahltrucker sind die dümmste Erfindung der Menschheit.
Jedes Mal, wenn du davon irgendwas brauchst, geht's nicht richtig.
Geht's nicht richtig.
Drecksding, Alter.
So.
Pog, moin.
Ja, Moritz, ich wusste nicht, ob du MW2 jetzt noch spielen willst oder nicht.
Schon so spät, ich hab nur nichts gehört. Ich hab gedacht, ich mach jetzt Stream an.
Ich weiß nicht.
Im Zweifelsfall spiele ich morgen auch ein paar Runden.
Die SMD-Profis sind in der Abendstadt. Nee, nee, nee. Onstream kann ich das nicht spielen.
Ich raste aus, wenn ich das Solo spielen muss und vor allem, wenn ich irgendwas anderes als SMD spiele.
Ich hab vorhin mal wieder ein paar Runden kill-confirmed gespielt und das ist wirklich so krass.
Entweder ist es übelstens Rumgekämpfe oder ich hab nur die krassesten Aim-Götter und Ultra-Leute am Start im Game.
Und prinzipiell wirst du eh generell immer von der Seite gekillt, in allem außer TDM.
Man müsste eigentlich mal Crown War und so probieren.
Aber ich glaube, das ist auch Müll.
Ja, da bin ich, wenn ich so sicher worte, ob Luft das Beste ist.
Für AMD mag das vielleicht sein, aber ich tendiere aktuell eher zu einem Intel-System.
Ja, also dazu kann ich nur sagen, mir macht prinzipiell Battlefield 2042 deutlich mehr Spaß, weil ich den Multiplayer von Battlefield prinzipiell besser finde.
Das Problem ist nur, dass Battlefield 2042 kaum ein richtiges Battlefield ist und von der Qualität des Games her,
also wie das gemacht ist. Modern Warfare 2 hat auch seine richtigen Probleme.
Du hast beispielsweise das Menü, das stockt und ruckelt die ganze Zeit, dass die Performance auf dem PC generell nicht so geil ist.
Also Modern War, Unverwundbarkeits-Klitschen mit dem Schild und solche Geschichten.
Aber trotzdem muss ich sagen, handwerklich besser gemacht ist MW2 auf jeden Fall.
Wirklich viel Content an MW2 hat tatsächlich auch nicht.
MW2 hat jede Menge Spielmodi, die eigentlich zur Hälfte überflüssig sind.
Und ansonsten, ja, Anzahl an Maps hält sich jetzt auch in Grenzen.
Aber trotzdem, ich finde, detailreicher und handwerklich besser gemacht ist MW2 auf jeden Fall.
Dankeschön für die Subs, Leute. Ich habe dir die Hälfte übersehen.
Michael5billionen auch mal am Stand.
Nice.
Pog.
Falls du dein Twitch Integrationsprojekt, von dem du mal erzählt hast, noch rumfliegen hast und das noch funktioniert, wäre ich sehr...
Äh, warte mal, Archiv. Guck mal.
Ah, falscher Browser. Lul.
Kackel.
Ich so...
Was auch immer Levelcap da wieder will.
Archiv ist eigentlich richtig cringe-kackel zu sagen anstatt zu lachen, oder?
Aber so ist es halt.
Wie habe ich denn das genannt? Irgendwas mit ISC vielleicht?
Unter der Haube ISC ist.
Äh?
Jetzt können wir nämlich die Volltextsuche von meinem Trans...
Leute, seht ihr eigentlich, ich muss euch das jetzt mal erzählen, seht ihr eigentlich, wie high IQ das Archiv ist?
Danke übrigens für die Subs, Quatsch mit Soz.
Und TianLive. Danke Leute für die Subs.
Seht ihr eigentlich, wie high IQ das Archiv gemacht ist?
Das ist das, was ich sage im...
Im Stream wird transcripted in Text, dass man die durchsuchen kann.
Das ist richtig high IQ. Das ist per AI mit GPU-Rendering.
Also, wir haben einen Cloud-Server gemietet mit GPUs.
Und haben eine Woche lang alle meine Streams immer schief transkribieren lassen zu Text. Per AI.
Der Sirius Max richtig feifett gewesen.
So, vielleicht finden wir das hier nämlich jetzt.
Irgendwo was, wo ISC drinnen vorkommt.
Ryzen 3, das kann nicht sein.
Ah ja, ist mit Chat.
Chat-Analyse.
Du musst mal suchen, wir haben...
Wir haben das, das ist hier irgendwo im Archiv, ist das Stream drin. Ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Wir haben das zusammen im Stream programmiert.
Kleiner Twitch-Tool oder sowas?
Nein, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Kleiner Twitch suchen?
5 bis 8 von 639, fuck.
Man müsste suchen nur nach Titel einschränken können. Ob es nur im Titel...
Oder nee, die Titel kommen zuerst.
Also, du musst mal suchen. Wir haben das programmiert im Stream.
Und irgendwo im Archiv ist es. Ich weiß wirklich nicht mal, wie der Titel hieß von dem Stream.
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist auf jeden Fall irgendwo im Archiv.
Es ist simpel gewesen. Das ist ISC.
Das ist ISC, wo man sich connecten kann, ohne anzumelden an den Twitch-Chat.
Da muss man nach den ISC...how to join Twitch-ISC-Chat oder sowas mal googeln.
Da siehst du das, wie das funktioniert. Das ist ziemlich einfach gewesen.
Ja, der SA mir war nicht neu genug. Ich will was ganz Neues. Ich will Neues und High-End.
Also es gibt eine Sache, die wenn ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufe, immer sein muss.
Der neue Rechner muss in allen Belangen mindestens so gut, aber eigentlich in allen Belangen besser.
Es sei denn, es ist komplett unverhältnismäßig.
Dann auch mindestens so gut, also gleich gut, wie der alte Rechner sein.
Das heißt, ich habe aktuell ein 8700k. Das heißt, da muss jetzt ein 13900k rein.
Oder dann ein entsprechender Ryzen. Aber ich tendiere aktuell tatsächlich wieder zum Intel, wobei es letzten Monat noch AMD war.
Ich habe eine 1080ti, da muss jetzt eine 4090 rein.
Ich habe 32G RAM, DDR4, da müssen jetzt eigentlich 64G DDR5 rein, wenn das nicht zu teuer wird.
Ich habe eine 10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte, die bleibt auf 10 Gigabit. Mehr bringt mir ja eh nix.
Also wisst ihr, da muss überall noch ein drauf gesetzt werden.
Aktuell 512G NVMe SSD, müssen dann 2TB NVMe SSD sein.
Warum gehst du nicht wieder zurück zur deutschen Telekom Technik GmbH in Frankfurt? Was heißt hier zurück?
Keck. Woher willst du wissen, dass ich jemals bei der Telekom war?
Ich finde Wasser bei den neuen... Was? Ja, das denke ich mir nämlich auch.
Ich auch. Vielleicht wird nämlich wirklich das mein erster Rechner mit Wasserkühlung.
Tja. Vielleicht.
Übrigens, wisst ihr eigentlich was? Wisst ihr, dass Online Police Twitch ein richtig krasser GTA Hacker-Man ist?
Wisst ihr, woher ich das weiß?
Ich habe heute seinen Comment unter meinem Video gesehen. Auf YouTube.
Und da habe ich auf seinen Kanal geklickt. Und das einzige Video, was sich auf diesem Kanal befindet, ist irgendwie sinngemäß GTA-Server zerstören.
Jetzt drehen die Cheater richtig durch oder irgendwie sowas in die Richtung.
Irgendwas, ich weiß den Titel nicht mal genau.
Da habe ich dann an drei Stellen durchgedrückt und habe mir gedacht, WTF, was bin ich sehend?
Das habe ich mir ausgemacht. Ja, zumindest scheinen GTA-Rollplay-Server einige Schwachstellen zu haben, wenn ich das so richtig gesehen habe.
Dass man zum Beispiel über irgendwelche... Ich weiß nicht, wie es genau funktioniert.
Dass man irgendwelche JavaScript-Lücken als Admin-Interface dran kommt und sowas. Wo ich mir auch schon wieder gedacht habe, meine Güte, es ist überall gleich.
War doch so, oder? Oder habe ich das falsch gelesen?
Irgendwelche... Ja, richtig. Ich muss mal kurz gucken. Ja, es ist JavaScript, aber das ist wirklich nur ein Befehl.
Global ist Admin. Ernsthaft? Krasser Scheiß. Warum ist das überhaupt JavaScript?
Nur, dass ich das richtig verstehe. Das hat nichts mit dem GTA-Client zu tun, oder so.
Das ist auf der Webseite, wo man sich einloggen muss, um sich für den Server zu registrieren, oder wie ist das?
Warum kann man dann quasi... Warum ist JavaScript einseitig in GTA? Hä? Okay, was auch immer. Ich will es gar nicht so genau wissen.
Wo ist eine Rage-MP? Das habe ich schon mal gelesen. Das ist irgendein GTA-5-Mod. Was auch wohl die meisten Rollplay-Server und sowas verwenden.
Dass du überhaupt Custom-Server machen kannst. Ach, das ist in JavaScript programmiert.
Aber... Okay. Aber warum reicht es, wenn du auf dem Client global is admin gleich true setzt? Sollten das nicht irgendwelche extra Wege sein und nicht in jedem Client?
Okay, was auch immer. Keine Ahnung. Man muss nicht verstehen. Da haben sie sich wahrscheinlich nichts dabei gedacht.
Wie deine Aufzeichnung zu IT-Stellen anzeigen? Ach ja! Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie du das meinst aus deinem Stream heute.
Mir fällt dazu was ein. Soll ich euch mal was sagen, was mit meiner Bewerbung passiert ist, Leute? Wollt ihr es wissen? Postchamp? Soll ich es euch sagen?
Corona? Nee. Corona ist bei der letzten Bewerbung passiert. Also ich sage es euch. Ich sage es euch. Ich sage es euch, Leute.
Es hat zwei Tage gedauert, als ich meinen Lebenslauf und meine Skill-Liste abgeschickt habe. Wie gesagt, ihr müsst dazu wissen.
Ich wurde ja angeschrieben von einem Ex-Kollege, der jetzt dort arbeiten hat. Er hat gemeint, Max, wir haben einen Job für dich.
Ich habe einen Lebenslauf hingeschickt, Skill-Liste. Und ihr glaubt es euch, zwei Tage später habe ich eine Antwort bekommen.
Ist soweit durch. Nächste Woche oder irgendwie die Tage gibt es Einladungen zum Gespräch. Guck mal, wie schnell das gehen kann.
Guck mal, wie schnell das gehen kann, wenn man keine Personalabteilung und sonstige Leute hat, die den ganzen Tag Däumchen drehen.
Mal gucken, wie das ist. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich bin mir ja noch nicht mal sicher, je nachdem, ob ich mich mit denen überhaupt einig werde.
Na gut, was heißt Connections? Connections wäre es ja gewesen, wenn ich gesagt hätte, ey, ich habe gesehen, du arbeitest da, kannst mal ein gutes Wort für mich einlegen.
War es ja gar nicht. Die haben ja mich angeschrieben. Naja, zumindest bin ich mal gespannt.
Also, wie gesagt, vielleicht werde ich mir mit denen auch nicht einig. Wie gesagt, es muss ja übereinstimmen, was vier Tage Woche angeht,
was Remote-Arbeiten angeht, was Gehalt angeht natürlich auch. Wie sah die Skill-Liste jetzt am Ende aus?
Hast du sie nochmal angepasst? Ja, aber nicht viel. Nicht viel, die kann ich euch jetzt gerade nicht zeigen.
Hab ich nicht hier. Aber das ist mehr oder weniger die gleiche Sache, die ich auch im Stream erstellt habe.
Ich habe ein paar Sachen rausgeschmissen, also ich habe zwei, drei Sachen rausgeschmissen, so Sachen wie Vim oder so, habe ich da unter Bekannte Tools noch gemacht.
Ich zeige es euch dann. Ich zeige es euch bei Gelegenheit mal. Erinnere mich dran.
Davon wissen, was deine Gehaltsvorstellungen sind. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, dass hier der Chat schon infiltriert ist und ich mir damit jetzt irgendwas versauere, wenn ich es erzähle.
Also, du kannst dir mal ein Video auf YouTube angucken, wo ich gesagt habe, was ich zum damaligen Zeitpunkt verdient habe.
Es ist mittlerweile ein bisschen mehr und drunter will ich das eh nicht machen. Also mir schwebt irgendwie sowas vor.
Ich meine, es muss sich lohnen, wenn man wechselt. Es sollte ja auch mal irgendwie ein bisschen was bringen.
Zumal bei mir eh aktuell ist es mal Zeit, für das es mehr Geld gibt. Also ich rechne das jetzt übrigens auf fünf Tage hoch.
Also ihr wisst, ich arbeite nur vier Tage, aber ich sage es euch jetzt für fünf Tage. Ja, irgendwas so um...
Ah, sagen wir mal. 85k. Sowas vor in der Richtung.
Also dafür würde ich es machen. Das müsste man jetzt natürlich mal runterrechnen.
Also, wie viel ist das in vier Tagen dann? Leute, kann man das so rechnen, wie ich das mache?
Kann man das mal 0,8 rechnen? Ja, 20% weg. 68k in vier Tage dann.
Ich meine, wenn sie natürlich mich sofort davon überzeugen wollen, können sie auch mehr sagen, dann unterschreibe ich direkt.
Nee, ich unterschreibe nicht direkt. Also das ist klar. Ich werde nicht direkt unterschreiben, ohne dass ich mal zumindest ein bisschen Einblick da gekriegt habe.
Wer weiß, wie es da ist. Vielleicht ist es ja noch schlimmer.
Ja, und ich will halt auch, dass das Homeoffice technisch geklärt ist.
Weil irgendwelche Bekenntnisse, dass man Homeoffice vorhat zu machen und dann sich das ein halbes Jahr später anders überlegt, habe ich jetzt schon genug erlebt.
Top, also.
Warum ist das unnötig rausgeschmissenes Geld? Wie kann die beste Hardware, die man sich aktuell kaufen kann, rausgeschmissenes Geld sein?
Ja, ist aktuell so geplant. Was soll ich mir denn sonst holen?
Wenn ich mir schon einen neuen Rechner kaufe. Mein Rechner ist ja aktuell gar nicht so schlecht, obwohl er schon uralt ist.
Hast du gerade? Hast du gerade die falsche Uhr gepostet? Oder ist das was lokales?
In Pognito Punkt E ist ein 6 Head Name.
Interne Domain. Aber das ist ziemlich gut. Ziemlich guter Name.
Willst du dann auch auf 4K umsteigen? Ich bin am überlegen, ob ich mir ein OLED Display holen soll.
Da ist es ja mit Reaktionszeiten alles nochmal richtig in der Nummer besser. Da muss es dann auch keine 1240 Hertz sein.
Silver Cross. Wenn ich es vergessen sollte, erinnere mich dran. Ich zeige es im nächsten Stream.
Da kann ich mich auch einloggen, wenn ich es vergessen sollte. Da steht nichts Geheimes drin, aber ich habe jetzt keinen Bock.
Da müsste ich das Handy holen, das Handy einloggen, mir das Ding per Mail hier rüber schicken und dann Copy Paste vom 2. Rechner.
Wer ist das, der das gesucht hat mit dem Stream Tool? Achieve. Nach was muss ich suchen?
Streamer Fragentool. Web Interface.
Oh nein. Damals durfte man noch auf Twitch Musik spielen.
Stellt euch das mal vor. Das ist ja schon ewig her. Wann war das? 2019. Das war vor Corona und bevor alle auf Twitch aufmerksam geworden sind.
Hier Leute, by the way, wer auf Power, Epic, sonst was, Heavy Metal, Metal steht und wer beispielsweise auch Bock auf Herr der Ringe Zeug hat, aber die Amazon Serie nicht sehen wollte,
hört euch das Album an. Also wer was mit Epic Power Metal anfangen kann, ist eines der besten Power Metal Alben aller Zeiten meiner Ansicht nach.
Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr nice. So, da ging es jetzt aber gar nicht rum. Ich glaube, das hier ist der Stream.
Streamer Fragentool. Web Interface.
Da hole ich eine Domain.
Ja hier, da, guck mal, da ist es doch. Ein Blind Guardian Enjoyer, genau. Da ist es doch hier. Also den kannst du dir angucken.
Wie auch immer es war, war irgendwie ein relativ kurzer Name. Da sieht man, wie ich das gemacht habe und das ist easy gewesen.
Das ist wirklich easy gewesen. Hier, Justin Fan plus ID. Random ID. Das war wirklich easy, Twitch Chat anzuzapfen per IRC.
Also bei mir in der Ausbildung war es so, dass ich einen Tag nachdem ich, also zur Ausbildung, einen Tag nachdem ich das Vorstellungsgespräch hatte,
haben die mich angerufen morgens um kurz vor 8. Das war die Zeit, wo ich 24-7 Kreiselgrind gemacht habe in MMOs und eigentlich gepennt habe bis 12.
Ich habe dann angerufen und ich dachte, Alter, was ist denn jetzt los? Und ich habe es dann gar nicht so erst realisiert.
Ich habe dann so gedacht, ja okay, alles klar, tschüss. Bis ich dann realisiert habe, dass ich eine Ausbildungsstelle habe.
Ich habe damals gleich meine Mutter noch angerufen und ich sagte, ihr Mama, ich glaube, ich habe eine Ausbildungsstelle und die ist voll ausgeflippt.
Ich habe mir so gedacht, Alter, es ist viel zu früh. Ich flippe jetzt nicht aus. Ich gehe jetzt einfach noch 4 Stunden pennen.
Und dann, was war das nächste, was ich gemacht habe? Ich habe im Wohnzimmer gestanden, habe mit ihr telefoniert.
Danach habe ich meine Mutter angerufen, dass ich eine Ausbildungsstelle habe. Die hat sich dann ewigst übelst gefreut.
Das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich. Ich glaube, alle Eltern freuen sich darüber. Und mein nächster Gedanke war, ohne Mist, ich kann mich heute noch daran erinnern.
Ich stehe im Wohnzimmer, lege das auf, rufe meine Mutter an, lege da auch auf und dann denke ich mir so,
okay, ich gehe jetzt erst noch mal 3 Stunden pennen. Und dann, das nächste war, nachdem ich gedacht habe, ich gehe jetzt 3 Stunden pennen,
okay, was steht heute Abend MMO technisch an? Ich kann mich beißen. Was ist heute Abend irgendwie?
Ist Raid, ist irgendwie sonst wie Farmen, ist RVR, was ist angesagt? Scheiß auf Ausbildung, MMO, Kreiselkrain, Farmen.
Du warst bei mir in Frankfurt bei der Telekom, so, so. Oh man. Du kommst auch mit WebIRC drauf, ja.
Also wie gesagt, das, weißt du, ich habe eine Ausbildung, das hat mich überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Mich hat viel eher interessiert, was ich abends dann wieder Kreiselkrainen musste.
Ist dir die 4 Tage oder Remote wichtiger? Beides. Beides. Also das ist beides für mich jetzt, nichts entweder oder Frage.
4 Tage, ich gehe nie wieder 5 Tage arbeiten. Dafür ist mir quasi einfach mein Wohlergehen zu wichtig.
War eine geile Zeit vor der Ausbildung, yo. Ich kenne einen, der ist damals auch öfters zu Anime-Conventions gefahren und sowas.
Also das ist für mich wie gesagt gar nicht mehr so die Frage entweder, entweder oder. Also das ist für mich beides wichtig.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ging super schnell mit der Einladung. Athen oder Englisch für den Sub.
Das ging super schnell mit der Einladung. Ich habe die, wann habe ich die Bewerbung abgeschickt? Lass mal überlegen.
Ich habe am Montag mit ihm telefoniert. Ich habe am...
Wann haben wir das geschrieben? Letzte Woche, oder? Kurz gucken.
Ich kann euch nicht sagen, Tag später habe ich das abgeschickt alles. Hier.
Also sprich, Mittwoch oder sowas. Keine Ahnung, ich habe das letzte Woche abgeschickt und habe dann jetzt 2 Tage später die Antwort bekommen, so nach dem Autogesprich. Auf geht's.
Hey Max, wie wahrscheinlich ist es mit dem Ingenieurstudium in die IT-Branche zu kommen? Ich denke mal ein Informatiker... Ach Quatsch, es kommt immer drauf an, was du kannst.
Und wenn es in einem Bereich ist, wo du Ahnung von hast, warum nicht? Ich meine, du kannst natürlich als Quereinsteiger nicht einfach sagen, ich bin Quereinsteiger, habe von nichts eine Ahnung und nehm mich, weil das ergibt ja keinen Sinn.
Das können übrigens Leute, die eine Ausbildung gemacht haben im IT-Bereich auch nicht unbedingt machen.
Ich meine, natürlich macht es, in gewisser Weise hast du bessere Chancen, wenn du beispielsweise Physik gelernt hast oder ein Informatikstudium gemacht hast.
Aber wenn du komplett keine Ahnung hast, dann ist auch da schwierig was zu kriegen. Ich meine, du musst zumindest mal es schaffen, ein bisschen von dem zu wissen, was die haben wollen.
Sei es nur ein bisschen Ahnung und wenn du ein bisschen Ahnung hast... Also das geht schon. Zumal das jetzt ja auch nicht zwangsläufig so weit weg ist, wenn du dich damit beschäftigst.
Was wird der neue Rechner? Wahrscheinlich eine Intel-Kiste. Würdest du auch 35 Stunden nehmen? Nö. Das ist ja quasi 3,5 Tage dann, äh 4,5 Tage dann.
Ich meine, man könnte sich drüber unterhalten, wenn es dann irgendwie auf 4 Tage auf, aber ganz ehrlich, 35 Stunden ist ja quasi fast schon, das ist ja im Endeffekt eine 5-Tage-Woche.
Oder alternativ müsstest du halt ewig lange arbeiten für 4 Tage.
Ja, noch nett. Noch nett.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich großartig auf 4K-Gaming... Ich werde mir wahrscheinlich einen OLED-Bildschirm holen, aber nicht in 4K, sondern irgendwie ein bisschen was drunter. Aber nicht mal 1080p, schon ein bisschen was größeres.
Was ist mein Budget-Limit fürs Mainboard? Der Gramm, ohne Mist. Der Gramm ist so teuer. Ich könnte mir ohne Probleme einen 4-500€-Mainboard kaufen, will ich aber nicht, weil warum unnötig teuer machen?
Das Ding ist ja nicht so, als können die Dinger irgendwie was großartig besser, wenn man jetzt nicht der krasse Übertakter ist oder 20 PC-Express-Slots braucht.
Also, oder bessere Spannungswandler fürs Übertakter. Also wofür braucht man ein ultra teures Mainboard?
Ja gut, die haben 10 Gigabit Onboard, aber wozu brauche ich das? Ich kann einfach eine 40€ 10G-Karte von Ebay reinstecken, das funktioniert auch.
Mehr RAM ist wichtig. Na ja gut, mehr RAM ist wirklich wichtig, Leute. Ihr wisst, zack, guckt mal da, Auslastung, 10GB. Und ohne, dass ich irgendeinen VM habe oder so. Ohne, dass ich eine VM auf habe.
Wenn ich eine VM starte, ihr kennt das, dann bin es eben auch mal bei 32G relativ weit oben. Ich sage mal, warum habe ich eigentlich 10GB, bitteschön, RAM-Auslastung?
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln? Ich meine, ich habe doch nichts auf. Ich habe OBS auf, drei Browser, 10GB. Was ist denn das?
Man kann es davon abgesehen, ihr wisst ja, was ich immer sage. Freier RAM ist verschenkter RAM. Also gut, dass das belegt wird.
Oled 4K 100, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein 4K wird, vielleicht wird es auch nur ein 2K oder sowas.
Neue Rechte, da gucken wir gerade. Ateno, Dankeschön für den Sub. Ich schaue mal kurz an, ich habe wieder die Hälfte an Subscriptions übersehen. Subscribers. Ateno, Tian Life, Quatsch mit Soos und Michael 50 Milliarden.
Ich habe dich zwar schon gesehen, aber trotzdem noch mal Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs. Du hast die Erfahrung gemacht, dass es teilweise sehr schnell gehen kann, auch bei Konzernen.
Ja gut, hängt halt bei allen davon ab, wie auf Zack die Personalabteilung ist bzw. die, die sich um den Bewerbungsprozess kümmern.
Negativ Beispiel, dort wo ich gerade aktuell arbeite, die erzählen ja auch an allen Ecken und Enden so, oh nein, Fachkräftemangel und ganz furchtbar schlimm.
Und ich habe einen ReLive-Kolleg, bringt jetzt nichts da, Verwandtschaft bzw. Bekanntschaftsverhältnisse zu umschreiben.
Ich kenne einen, der macht gerade eine Umschulung zum Fachinformatiker und da hatte ich bei uns, bei unserem Ausbildungschef nachgefragt, wie sieht denn das aus mit, kann er bei uns ein Praktikum machen,
weil die müssen, damit sie die Prüfung ablegen können, müssen sie neun Monate Praktikum machen im Betrieb. Hab ich gefragt, wie sieht denn das bei uns aus, können wir das machen?
Und das war würde typisch für uns, ja, erste Mal kriege ich die Antwort, ja, sind noch ganz viele ungeklärten Sachen, habe ich gesagt, ok, was denn genau?
Haben sie mir das geschrieben, habe ich ihnen das gefragt, habe ihm dann ein paar Tage später die Antwort hingeschickt zu seinen Fragen, keine Reaktion.
Dann habe ich ein paar Tage später nochmal nachgefragt, keine Reaktion.
Dann habe ich meinen Chef gefragt, mein Chef hat dann dort nochmal nachgefragt und dann habe ich noch am gleichen Tag die Absage bekommen, dass die den nicht gebrauchen können und ich wette mit euch.
Die haben das einfach nur abgesagt, weil sie keinen Bock hatten nachzugucken.
Wisst ihr, ich war hartnäckig und habe halt ein paar Mal gefragt und komischerweise, sobald ich dann über die offiziellen Wege nochmal habe nachfragen lassen, hieß es sofort, ne geht nicht.
Was im Endeffekt für mich heißt, man hat das im Vorfeld gar nicht probiert.
Man hat gedacht, alter, wen juckt's?
Und als ich dann hartnäckig war, hat man einfach gesagt, ja, ne geht nicht.
Und dann muss man sich nicht wundern.
Also wenn ich ausbilden will und wenn ich ein bisschen an der Nachwuchsförderung beteiligen will, dann muss man sich nicht beschweren, wenn man keine Leute kriegt.
Ja und vor allem, was macht das für einen Eindruck, wenn man sich vorstellt, das ist quasi so der Admin von morgen, der gerade die Ausbildung macht und wenn du sowas mitkriegst, da weißt du schon, wo du nicht hingehst.
Ja, stimmt schon.
Also sprich, selbst wenn er jetzt seine Ausbildung fertig hat, bei irgendeinem anderen Laden, da geht er wahrscheinlich nicht hin.
Wie gesagt, wahrscheinlich ein Intel-Kiss.
Ich bin mir mit Ryzen for the Win gar nicht mehr so sicher.
So Top-Leistung ist aktuell gerade wie der Intel.
Ach, Quatsch.
Das war doch nur bei dem Originalkabel und nur bei geknickten Kabeln oder so, dass die RTX gebrannt hat.
Embedded-Entwickler, frag mal den Patrick aus der Schweiz, Alter, der verdient sich dumm und dämlich damit.
Nee, aber 10 GB RAM kann es trotzdem nicht verbrauchen.
Guck mal, was habe ich denn an Taps auf?
Was meint ihr, wie viele Taps das hier insgesamt sind?
40?
Das darf doch keine 10 GB RAM verbrauchen.
Grund dafür ist, dass krumme Skalierung auf Linux nicht gut aussieht.
Joho, danke schön für den Sub.
Was für eine krumme Skalierung.
Die Freunde wollen wahrscheinlich da auch nicht hin hören, weil er das denen erzählt.
Gut, also, jetzt können wir mal nach dem neuen Rechner gucken.
Gut, wir haben ja irgendwo hier letzten schon mal eine Liste gemacht mit Hardware-Teilen.
Wo ich... das will ich bestimmt nicht spielen, MonkaS.
Wo immer ich die hin habe, habe ich die in der VM?
Habe ich die vielleicht in der VM gemacht?
Nee, das waren Spiele, die verkackt wurden, glaube ich, die Liste.
Was haben wir hier?
Das da?
Anthem hatte einen guten Soundtrack?
Weiß nicht.
Kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ich glaube, ich habe Anthem gar nicht gespielt.
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie viel RAM der mit der Browser verbraucht?
Oh, oh, es geht hoch, Leute.
Die Firemits gestartet.
20 GB.
Guck mal, der Browser braucht...
Ach so, Moment, da sind wieder 50.000 Chrome-Prozesse offen.
Da weiß man nicht, was der unterm Strich verbraucht.
Ah Mist, das habe ich zugemacht.
Ich wollte doch hier gucken.
Ist hier der PC?
Nee.
Okay, dann habe ich keinen Plan, wo ich die Sache mit dem PC habe.
Ist auch egal.
Letztendlich wird es wahrscheinlich eh eine neue zu sein.
Als letztes haben wir nämlich mit der AMD-Kiste geguckt.
Also, meine aktuellen Vorstellungen sind wie folgt für neuen PC.
13900K, eventuell F.
Chat, wer ist HiRQ und weiß, was der Unterschied zwischen K und KF ist?
Wenn nicht, sage ich es euch gleich, weil ich habe extra vorher nachgeguckt.
Nimm mal den Task Manager Form.
Korrekt.
Ich glaube, der F ist mit GPU.
Ist es nicht so, dass der F eine GPU hat und der K nicht?
Oder umgedreht?
Oder zumindest eins von beiden.
Also einer hat eine GPU mit drin und einer nicht.
Andersrum, wie macht man den Task Manager von Chrome auf?
Ich glaube, ich habe den Task Manager von Chrome noch nie aufgemacht.
Klar.
So.
Und wo sieht man jetzt den RAM-Verbrauch?
Das ist ja nichts.
Hier.
Also, was mir aktuell vorschwebt, ist folgendes.
13900K.
Da bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Ich glaube, AMD oder Intel habe ich mir vor dem Stream schon beantwortet.
Dann halt irgendein Mainboard.
Keine Ahnung.
Ob wieder S-Rock oder irgendwas anderes.
Letztendlich ist es auch nicht so wahnsinnig wichtig, von welchem Hersteller das kommt.
Mit einer 4090 weiß ich aber noch nicht welche.
Bin ich mir auch schon relativ sicher, dass es so eine werden soll.
Wo ich mir noch überhaupt nicht sicher bin, ist DDR4, 4 oder 5.
Wie groß ist der Leistungsunterschied zwischen 4 und 5?
Und wie groß ist der Leistungsunterschied zwischen 4 und 5 bei Anwendungsszenarien,
wo man es auch täglich macht?
Also, nur weil es jetzt in irgendeinem Scenebench oder in irgendeinem Renderbench mag vielleicht schneller,
heißt es ja nicht zwangsläufig, dass es tatsächlich in Games oder im Alltag irgendwelche Auswirkungen hat.
Da muss man gucken.
Okay, 2TB NVMe SSD, das auf jeden Fall.
Willst du deine Niere verkaufen? Nee.
Braucht man dafür auch nicht.
Es ist ganz einfach.
Man muss einfach mehr Geld behalten, als man Geld ausgibt.
Und dann kann man irgendwann auch mal mehr Geld ausgeben.
Wenn man natürlich immer mehr Geld ausgibt, als man behält, dann hat man nie Geld, um sich was kaufen zu können.
Und nachdem ich eigentlich sehr sparsam bin und so gut wie nie was kaufe, kann ich mir ab und zu auch mal was ordentliches kaufen.
DDR5 soll noch unerheblich sein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe es mir im Vorfeld nicht angeschaut.
Ich weiß nur, dass RAM-Preise, glaube ich, aktuell von allen Hardware-Kisten noch das beste sind.
Die sind zwar nicht mehr so billig wie noch vor einem Jahr, aber RAM-Preise sind, glaube ich, ganz erschwinglich.
Das sind 10%. Woher hast du das? Wo hast du es gelesen?
Oder hast du vielleicht irgendeinen Benchmark am Start?
Es gibt Boards, die DDR4 und 5 können. Ja, ja.
Also ich glaube, die meisten DDR5-Boards können DDR4, aber nicht umgedreht, oder?
Leute, wisst ihr eigentlich, wie heftig das ist?
Mein letzter PC, den ich mir da gekauft habe.
Max FPS-PC von 2017. Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen.
Mein PC ist 5 Jahre alt. 5 Jahre. Ziemlich genau 5 Jahre alt.
Und der hat damals, glaube ich, 2000... Ne, was hat denn der damals gekostet?
Man weiß es nicht mehr. Lul.
Ähm, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Definitiv nicht 4500, so viel kann ich sagen.
Ach so, ist das so, okay.
Ah ja gut, jetzt haben sie mal wieder die Nase beim RAM an einer anderen Stelle gemacht, dass du es nicht aus Versehen reinstecken kannst.
Zumindest der PC hat das 5 Jahre Gehalt und das war damals schon ziemlich, ziemlich high-end das Ding.
1080 Ti, 8700K. Ich hatte eine der ersten 8700Ks in Deutschland.
Und den hab ich geköpft damals. Ich hab noch nie so geschwitzt beim Hardware-Basteln.
Hab ich sogar aufgenommen, hab ich irgendwo noch. Hab ich nie hochgeladen.
Ja, und der hält jetzt auch 5 Jahre und eigentlich bräuchte ich gar keinen neuen.
Aber mir ist es einfach echt mal wieder danach. 5 Jahre, Alter, es wird mal Zeit.
Und ich hab jetzt so das Gefühl, so bei dieser CPU-Generation und sowas ist es soweit.
Auch weil die 4090 endlich mal wieder ein großer Sprung ist.
Wenn auch preislich und leistungstechnisch.
Verlost du die alte CPU in Mainboards und Subs? Nee.
Das wird der Streaming-Rechner.
Ich hab aktuell zwei Rechner, den alten und jetzt meinen neuen, der 5 Jahre alt ist.
Und dann wird der jetzige Streaming-Rechner und der andere.
Ich lass beide hier an. Beide hier. Was wegkommt, ist mein alter.
Mein alter Xeon... Moment.
Rechner, der wegkommt, ist der hier.
Wie alt ist Max? Ich bin 38. Kann mich grad vorstellen.
Hier. Der von 2013, der Rechner. Der kommt jetzt weg.
Hier. Der da mit dem Xeon drin. Der kommt jetzt weg.
Leute, glaubt mir, den will keiner von euch mehr haben. Das olle Ding.
9 Jahre alter Rechner. Keg-Wade.
Nee, das darfst du schon selbst rausfinden, wie das geht.
Ich hab dir jetzt schon den Stream verlinkt, wo ich gezeigt hab, wie's geht.
Gehst du direkt auf 64G RAM? Ja. Benutzst du dann eine Elgato?
Ich benutz jetzt schon eine Elgato. Ach, du meinst zum... Ach so. Ich noob.
Zum Captchern? Nö.
Was ist das für ein Ding?
Das ist ein Keg-Wade.
Ach so. Ich noob. Zum Captchern? Nö. Weiß ich nicht.
Ich stream weiter von dem Rechner hier. Den zweiten Rechner brauche ich nur
während dem Stream zur Vorschau und zum Chat lesen und so was.
Ich hab hier immer den Chat im Fullscreen.
Können die in der CPU eingebauten GPUs das?
Aber die NVIDIA-Karte kann ja bestimmt AV1-encoding.
Wahrscheinlich... vielleicht. Ich weiß nicht. Muss mal einen Steuerberater fragen.
Ja. Ist das schon ein Vier? Ist das ein Dual-Core oder ist das ein Quad-Core?
Den ich da hatte schon.
Okay. Hat schon vier Kerne gehabt.
Ja. Und dann hat es einfach Intel irgendwie sechs Jahre nicht hinbekommen, mehr als vier Kerne in Desktop-CPUs zu bauen.
Okay.
Naja. Die meisten Leute... AV1-encoding bringt doch eh nix.
Die meisten Leute haben doch gar kein Endgerät mit einem Hardware-Decoder.
Oder die ganzen Smartphones haben doch nur H264.
Hardware-Decoder. Oder haben die auch schon AV1-Hardware-Decoder?
Ja. Dann muss ich doch mal einen zweiten Rechner als Encoder benutzen.
Gut. Wie dem auch sei. Also das brauchen wir.
Und dann ist halt noch die Frage und da bin ich mir wirklich unschlüssig.
Wasserkühlung oder Luft?
Aktuell habe ich den hier. Guckt mal. Noctua DH15.
So einen habe ich aktuell.
Das ist ein ziemlich nicer Kühler.
Aber ich habe jetzt... Ihr wisst, dass ich kein großer Fan von Wasserkühlung bin.
Aber ich habe gelesen, dass es tatsächlich bei der aktuellen CPU-Generation zum ersten Mal wirklich...
Was heißt zum ersten Mal? Zum ersten Mal wohl richtig auch Auswirkungen zu spüren sind.
Auch im normalen Betrieb.
Also ohne krass zu übertacken.
Also vielleicht, vielleicht.
Willst du ein Silent-Bild? Was ist für dich ein Silent-Bild?
Ein Bild, wo wirklich kein rotierender Lüfter drin ist?
Oder ein Bild, was du bei einem im Desktop-Betrieb quasi nicht oder so gut wie gar nicht hörst?
Also ich brauche kein Passiv-Bild.
Ein Silent-Bild... Also...
Es sollte mich im Desktop-Betrieb nicht wegblasen und das macht mein aktueller Rechner nicht.
Ich bin mit der Geräuschentwicklung von meinem aktuellen Rechner komplett zufrieden.
Im Desktop-Betrieb ist der Noctua ziemlich leise.
Die Gehäuse-Lüfter hörst du auch kaum.
Und das Netzteil hörst du auch kaum.
Im Gaming fast nicht hörst.
Nee, das stört mich nicht großartig.
Im Gaming kann ich ruhig was hören.
Da habe ich einen Kopfhörer auf.
Das ist jetzt auch so. Wenn ich jetzt den Spiel anmache, dann höre ich auch den Lüfter und die Grafikkarte bis.
Aber nicht so, dass es schlimm wird.
RGB... RGB kann mich mal.
Ich brauche kein RGB.
Nächste, Wasserkühlung. Ja, ich spiele auch mit dem Gedanken, Wasserkühlung.
Weil bei der aktuellen CPU-Generation sollte es zum ersten Mal wohl wirklich so sein,
dass ich das wirklich auch im Normalbetrieb, also ohne den zu übertakken,
wenn du spielst und renderst, dass es dann wirklich was bringt.
Also ich will keinen. RGB brauche ich nicht.
3080. Ja, das ist auch ein guter Rechner.
3080 Ti ist halt die Frage, ob es sich lohnt. 3080 Ti kostet irgendwie 250 oder so mehr.
Und eigentlich lohnt es sich nicht.
Aber ganz ehrlich, die Sache ist halt die.
Ich könnte mir jetzt auch sowas hier in der Richtung kaufen.
Das bewegt sich dann preislich. Was hast du bezahlt? 2500 oder sowas?
Irgendwie in dem Dreh vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Vielleicht sogar ein bisschen billiger.
Vielleicht sogar ein bisschen billiger, wahrscheinlich 2000 nur oder sowas.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Naja, zumindest die Sache ist die.
Ich könnte mir jetzt auch ein Upgrade kaufen.
Auf sowas in der Richtung.
Aber ehrlich, ich will das Beste haben.
Wisst ihr, ich habe früher, wo ich klein war, habe ich mir so oft gewünscht,
zu irgendwie hol dir einen Rechner.
Ich hätte jetzt so gerne einen Rechner mit einer Voodoo SLI.
Und dann irgendwie dann und dann später.
Ich habe endlich drei Jahre gespart, dass ich mir mal eine TNT1 kaufen konnte und sowas.
Und ich habe mir damals gesagt, wenn ich später mir selbst Rechner kaufe,
dann kaufe ich mir immer nur richtig fette Kisten.
Habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ich habe es bisher immer preisleistungstechnisch eigentlich zumindest nicht total aus dem Ruder laufen lassen.
Aber ohne Scheiß, wenn ich meinen High-End Rechner Upgrade jetzt nach fünf Jahren
und soll das wieder absoluter High-End Rechner sein, das Beste, was es gibt,
dann habe ich wahrscheinlich wieder fünf Jahre Ruhe.
Ich meine, ich bräuchte jetzt ja noch nicht mal einen neuen Rechner.
Der alte, der kann, also ich habe MW2 gespielt.
MW2 ist wirklich nicht sonderlich toll optimiert auf dem PC.
Also ich habe irgendwie was um, ja, auf, also teilweise 130, 140 FPS,
wenn es die Maps sind mit vielen Gebäuden dazwischen,
wenn es die etwas offeneren Maps sind und nicht so gut optimierten Maps.
Irgendwas um 100 FPS mit, aber teilweise schon Drops auf 85 oder so.
Also bei den neuen, ich habe auch keine Ahnung von Wasserkühlung, das ist es ja.
Also bei den neuen wahrscheinlich gar nichts großartig.
Das ist jetzt so ein All-In-One-Ding, da hast du einen Radiator, du hast ein paar Schläuche
und du hast eben so ein Kühlelement für die CPU.
Und korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege, Leute, das war es eigentlich.
Also das setze dann da drauf und dann ist gut.
Muss man nichts machen, großartig, ja.
Wo bringt man denn den Radiator dann eigentlich an?
Gut, was willst du warten? Du meinst, wenn sie kaputt ist, oder wie?
Vorne oder oben am Gehäuse. Wo würde ich jetzt zum Beispiel?
Gibt es schon ein R7, wo würde ich zum Beispiel hier Bilder, please?
Offenes Case, please?
Von vorne, please?
Wo würde ich hier zum Beispiel jetzt die Wasserkühlung einbauen?
Also hier vorne, das ist eine Klappe, die kann man aufmachen und dahinter sind Gehäuselüfter.
Das sieht man jetzt hier irgendwie ziemlich, hier sieht man es gut.
Äh, fuck.
Ja, ein bisschen doof.
Hier, guck mal.
Oben, dann das Gitter, würde ich dann so ein Gitter nehmen?
Okay, mal, mal, Leute, mal, mal, nur mal so, von der Idee her.
Oben, oben dann die Wasserkühlung rein. Siehe, dass da eine 40-90 reinpasst, die ist sehr breit.
Also breit ist kein Problem. Das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich großes Gehäuse.
Würde mich wundern, wenn das da nicht reinpasst.
Also breit ist kein Problem. Das Gehäuse ist ziemlich geräumig.
Lang, wenn man da keinen Festplattenwechselrahmen unten rein macht, denke ich auch, das wird passen.
Das Gehäuse, ich habe massig Platz in dem Gehäuse. Ich sehe es ja jetzt schon.
Müssen wir mal schauen. So, also nur mal so von der Idee her.
Wenn ich hier oben die Wasserkühlung...
Warum Airflow? Naja, das ist das, was ich gerade sagen will.
Wenn ich hier oben die Wasserkühlung reinmachen würde, das Netzteil kommt dann unten hin.
Na, das Netzteil kommt hier unten hin. Reicht denn nicht der Airflow von hier vorne nach da hinten?
Ich meine, du hast ein bisschen Airflow durchs Gehäuse durch und du hast oben die Wasserkühlung drin.
Der Airflow ist doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Du hast unten das Netzteil, du hast hinten einen Lüfter.
Vorne ist alles zu? Nee, Quatsch, vorne ist nicht alles zu.
Okay, du hast eine Tür, aber die hat ja Luftschlitze.
Sie ist ja hier. Warte mal.
Das sieht man jetzt hier nicht richtig.
Also meine Tür vom Air 6 oder was ich hier habe oder Air 5, das hat Luftschlitze an der Seite.
Warum ist das Gehäuse nicht gut? Das ist Poggers. Echt, ist das so?
Besser wäre, wenn das Gehäuse vorne komplett offen wäre für Airflow.
Das Gehäuse zieht Luft quasi hier durch die Seite. Wo ist denn die Tür, Mann?
Hier, guck mal. Da hast du so Löcher für die Lüfter.
Meshify 2
War es an dem jetzt besser?
Also vorne offen, da muss auf jeden Fall ein Staubfilter rein.
Also ohne Staubfilter mache ich das nicht mehr.
Sag ich euch. Ah, da ist ein Staubfilter drin. Okay.
Und das ist jetzt so viel besser für den Airflow als wenn es von der Seite ziehen kann?
Okay, was Torrent Case. Ich sehe schon. Warum haben die eigentlich tausend verschiedene?
Okay, das sieht cool aus. Das sieht aus wie ein Heizlüfter.
Haben die da die Wasserkühlung unten oder ist das einfach nur immer überall voller Kühler?
Das ist ein Heizlüfter. Stimmt ehrlich gesagt auch.
Bei einem maximalen Verbrauch von 700 Watt oder so mit GPU und CPU auf Anschlag.
Ach, gucke mal da. Das habe ich ja ewig nicht gesehen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das Netzteil oben Sachen gibt es.
Okay, da muss ich mir noch mal schlau machen, was man da am besten.
Ich dachte Netzteil oben ist out. Ja, letztendlich ist mir vollkommen egal, wo das Netzteil ist.
Das Netzteil hat den High Ground. So sieht es aus.
It's over.
Okay, oben sieht das typisch Fractal Design mäßig aus.
Das gefällt mir das Gehäuse. Soll ich euch das mal sagen?
Sir Clash? Nee, ich finde das sieht cool aus. Mir gefällt das.
Mir gefällt das Gehäuse. Ich finde das schick.
Gamer Nexus macht gute Reviews. Okay.
Okay, vom Preis her ist es ungefähr das gleiche.
Best Case of 2021. Ja, Gehäuse muss ich mir noch mal schlau machen.
Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt deutlich zu übertrieben, dass es das Netzteil irgendwie killen würde.
Das Netzteil hat einen Lüfter und da kommt ziemlich gut der Airflow durch.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt so will. Warum hat das überhaupt?
Ja, glaube ich. Warum hat das überhaupt unten noch mal so extra Lüfter?
Na gut.
Wollen wir uns das mal 25 Minuten? So, wir schauen jetzt erst mal was anderes.
Was kostet mich denn aktuell so ein Ding?
K und KF. Der KF ist billiger.
Leute, was meint ihr? Ich meine, ich habe eine Nvidia Grafikkarte drinne.
Brauche ich überhaupt eine CPU mit GPU drinne? Eigentlich nicht.
Fällt euch irgendein Anwendungszweck ein?
Wozu man das brauchen könnte?
Irgendwas für Video Rendern vielleicht?
Also zum Beispiel OBS den Stream rendern lassen.
Aber ganz im Ernst, die GPU, die Coder langweilen sich in-Game auch.
QEMO. Ich benutze Windows. Das geht nicht.
Schauen wir mal, was hier der preisliche Unterschied ist, wenn es lagert.
Trey. Warum?
Ok, nur mal eine bescheuerte Frage. Boxed ohne Kühler und Trey.
Ist das nicht exakt das Gleiche? Früher war bei Boxed immer noch ein Kühler dabei.
Und ein kleines Handbuch.
Ach, Boxed hat Garantie. Trey muss auch Garantie haben, weil er kaputt geht.
Lagert.
Ok, ich nehme KF ganz im Ernst.
Die kann ich mir, die kann ich mir sparen.
Also müssen wir ungefähr 720 Euro rechnen so in dem Dreh.
Ok, also CPU kostet 720 Euro. Ganz schön teuer für eine CPU.
Ich glaube ich 450 bezahlt für den 8700K.
So, also die CPU ist schon mal klar.
Ich glaube das komplizierteste wird eh Mainboard.
Ok, wir müssen mal den RAM preislich vergleichen.
Und welche 4090 sind dann aktuell überhaupt lieferbar?
Ähm, Grafikkarten, PC, eExpress, den können wir gleich hier machen. 4090.
Was ist denn die billigste?
Manly. Alter, die Gigachat Grafikkarte oder was ist das?
Manlich? Manly? Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Hab ich noch nie gehört. Was ist Manly?
Cybertank.
Hat eine ziemliche Kackfarbe. Was zur...
Moment.
Warum ist da eine Wasserwaage dran?
Ist das jetzt ein Gag?
Oder hat das einen Sinn? Und warum ist da ein Batteriesymbol?
Ne.
Eno 3D, 3D iChill X3. Oh, von denen hatte ich mal eine Grafikkarte.
Von denen hatte ich mal eine. Hab ich mal tatsächlich damals noch von Nvidia selbst bekommen.
Das war eine 9, 180 TI glaube ich. Die hatte den besten Namen überhaupt.
Hercules iChill.
Windforce.
iChill Hercules X3 Ult. Moment, das ist dann der richtige.
Ja, da ist sie. Ne.
Die hatte den besten Namen überhaupt.
Airboss, da ist sie doch, Leute.
Eno 3D, 980 iChill X4 Airboss Ultra Windforce. Windforce war da auch noch drinne im Namen.
Das, das war ein Name für eine Grafikkarte, oder?
Das ist die mit diesem Minilüfter nebendran, wo ich nie verstanden habe, was dieser Minilüfter nebendran soll.
Pro Shop. Kann man das anklicken?
Wieso gibt es auch überall 40, 90 oder? 40, 90.
Oh, das geht doch eigentlich. Auf Lager ganze 4. Wow.
Warum ist sie so günstig?
Demo? Wait a minute, Demo? Was für, was ist Demo?
Demo?
Ach so, das ist quasi gebraucht.
Ganz wichtig, der Gardener Haken.
Eno 3D, iChill, Windforce.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, welche davon jetzt genau.
Letztendlich macht es wahrscheinlich gar keinen allzu großen Unterschied.
Aber kurzfristig lieferbar noch dabei.
Pro Shop? Ist das tatsächlich relativ günstig jetzt im Vergleich zu den anderen?
Warum sind die nicht bei?
Warum sind die nicht bei Geizhals?
Mit dabei?
Weil das geht ja hier im Prinzip. Weil das Schweden oder Finnen sind.
Aber gut, die verschicken doch aus Deutsch, oder?
Aufgrund geringer Verfügbarkeit und lange Wahrzeit nehmen wir derzeit keine weiteren Bestellungen an.
Wie jetzt? Das steht auf Lager. Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ach so, Montag bis Freitag.
What the fuck? Was ist das?
Komm, wir gucken mal bei Amazon, da kostet es bestimmt das Dreifache.
Boah, Amazon Preise.
Store?
Gibt es wirklich im offiziellen Nvidia Store was zu kaufen?
Tatsächlich, na Moment, jetzt kaufen kannst du knicken.
Ich gehe davon aus, wenn du sagst, jetzt kaufen.
Okay, okay.
Gibt es schon mal gar nicht?
Nicht lagern, siehst du?
Warum hat Nvidia eigentlich irgendwelche Reflinks? Kannste vergessen.
Ja, da muss ich mal gucken, was das gibt.
Kommt eBay für mich in Frage, wenn es ein Shop ist schon.
Aber nichts, nichts Gebrauchtes.
Und auch nichts von irgendwelchen Privatsellern.
Ja, Patrick, bin ich.
Also ich sehe Grafikan, außer Manly, von denen ich noch nie was gehört habe.
Ordentlicher Preis hier.
2449, warum keine 7900?
Weil die noch nicht raus sind und es noch keine richtigen Benchmarks und alles gibt.
Aber es gibt Vermutungen, ja, den Vermutungen nach soll die ungefähr.
Was war das?
Ich habe letztens ein Video geguckt.
Irgendwie in die Nähe kommen von der 4090, aber nicht, aber nicht schneller oder so.
Ja, ich glaube sogar, dass ich das Video geguckt habe.
Wie gesagt, ich kaufe wahrscheinlich erst, wenn ich dann Urlaub dieses Jahr habe.
Also in zwei Wochen, wenn es dann noch was gibt, aber in drei Wochen.
Okay, das Zeug ist ganz schön teuer, aber wird sich schon was finden.
Also ich denke mal, wir werden so um 2300 Euro rechnen müssen für die 4090.
Das wird ganz schön teuer Leute, wir sind jetzt schon bei 3000.
Überlegt euch mal, krasser Scheiß, oder?
Nur CPU und GPU schon 3000 Euro.
What the fuck?
Das ist mal eine Hausnummer.
Ja, das ist wirklich eine Hausnummer.
Schauen wir mal nach Ram.
Stimmt, wollte ich gucken.
Anwaltspeicher.
Okay, wir machen mal DDR4 und DDR5.
Ach ja.
Welche Taktraten denn eigentlich?
Also ich glaube aktuell habe ich, Moment.
Aktuell habe ich 3200 RGB Ram.
Weil RGB.
Nicht, dass ich RGB Ram brauchen würde.
Nein, maximal kannst du dir bei Ram nicht leisten.
Ich glaube, 3200 ist wahrscheinlich so mit das Beste, was man noch halbwegs erschwinglich bekommt, oder?
Okay, zeig mal her.
Alter.
Nee.
Das ist zu heftig.
Okay, DDR5.
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Preis pro Gigabyte.
Was ist günstig?
Nein, Preis pro Gigabyte.
What the?
RGB.
Ich will RGB.
Nein, ich will nicht RGB, aber mal gucken, was mit RGB ist.
Was unterstützt die CPU maximal?
Weiß ich nicht.
Wir müssen aber da auch gucken, was das Mainboard und so alles unterstützt.
Was hatte ich noch mal für einen Ram hier?
Ich hatte doch den da.
G-Skill.
Moment, das ist falsch.
Trident.
Okay, die gibt es auch in allen möglichen Ausführungen.
Preis pro Gigabyte.
Nein, ich will das günstigste Preis.
Hä?
Ach, hier.
Preis pro Gigabyte.
Das sollte vielleicht auch da hinten markieren.
Was ist dir bei deinem neuen PC wichtig?
Dass es mindestens so gut ist in allen Belangen wie mein aktueller PC, aber eigentlich sollte
es in allen Belangen schneller sein.
Das heißt 64G statt 32G RAM.
4090, 13900.
Ich will eigentlich das Beste haben, was es gibt.
Geld spielt aber schon insofern noch eine Rolle, dass wenn es jetzt ganz abgedreht ist,
ein Prozent mehr CPU-Last, ein Prozent mehr Leistung, irgendwie das Doppelte, dann mache
ich das nicht.
Es muss irgendwie noch in gewisser Weise nachvollziehbar sein.
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
DDR5 5200.
5600.
Warum kosten die so viel?
Ah, wegen den Timings, oder?
Das sind 83.
Ich habe übrigens mittlerweile absolut keinen Plan mehr, was die RAM Timings ausmachen.
Wirklich, ich habe null.
Absolut null Ahnung.
Du du du du.
64G.
Packungsgröße, wobei es eigentlich egal ist, kann ich doppelt nehmen.
Also sagen wir mal, der günstigste, komm mal RGB weg.
RGB ist Blödsinn.
Also das heißt, das günstigste, was ich mir an RAM kaufen kann, ist im Endeffekt
RG Skill Overkill.
Auf was muss man?
Ich habe halt echt keinen Plan.
Was ist denn jetzt?
Wir müssen erst Mainboard gucken.
Wir müssen erst Mainboard gucken und da muss ich schauen, was die, was die Mainboards
so so bringen.
Das ist nämlich ganz ganz billig billig.
Shit, das muss nicht sein.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich fast schon mindestens 500 Euro für den RAM ausgeben
muss.
Das ist mir auch klar, aber das ist halt die Frage, in welchem RAM du kannst natürlich
den besten RAM der besten kaufen.
Das lohnt sich aber meistens nicht.
Ja, so nach dem Motto, für ein bisschen Timings drunter kostet es dann 200 Euro mehr.
Also das ist halt, müssen wir mal gucken, was die Mainboards, RGB Filter rein, hatte
ich doch schon.
So, vergleichen wir das mal mit DDR4.
So, wir haben jetzt nichts gefiltert.
Wir haben nichts gefiltert.
Preis pro Gigabyte.
Geht hier, geht hier los mit 2,2 pro Gigabyte und hier geht es los mit 3.
Das ist halt schon, sagen wir mal, so zwei Drittel teurer.
Ja, irgendein 40,90, aber ich weiß noch nicht genau welche.
Muss es ein bisschen davon abhängig, welche Lager sind und welche nicht.
Mal hier.
Das ist ohne, ohne RGB.
32,38,38,96.
Ist das DDR5 oder 4?
Aber das ist 6.000er.
Weiß gar nicht, ob sich das überhaupt lohnt.
Und das sind 64G.
Das ist doch ECC, nee ECC brauchen wir wirklich nicht.
Wir müssen erstmal nach dem Mainboard gucken, so wird das nix.
Ich hab da noch zu wenig Durchblick für, dass ich jetzt wüsste, was für ein RAM ich mir
das noch machen würde.
Schauen wir mal Mainboard.
Mainboards.
BIOS Flashback, ich gehe davon aus, dass haben die ganzen ein bisschen höher preisigen,
oder?
Nee?
Also es sollte auf jeden Fall DDR5 haben.
Ja, ob jetzt 2 oder 5 ist mir ziemlich egal.
SROC wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich hab jetzt letzten zwei Rechner hatten schon SROC-Mainboards.
Was ist ECC?
Ich bring das immer durcheinander, ob ECC oder Buffert.
Ich glaube ECC ist die Fehlerkorrektur, oder?
Ist ECC oder nur Fehlererkennung?
Fehlererkennung oder Fehlerkorrektur?
Das ist das, was die ganzen ZFS Jünger sagen, dass man ohne ECC-Ramen kein ZFS betreiben
darf, was natürlich vollkommener Schwachsinn ist.
Weil es wird dadurch auch nicht schlechter als andere Fallsysteme, die du ohne ECC-Ramen
betreibst.
Es ist eher noch besser als andere Dateilsysteme, die du auch ohne ECC-Ramen betreibst.
Das raucht es dann ab, nur weil du ZFS machst, wo du keinen ECC-Ramen hast.
Aber guck mal ins Freena's Forum.
Auch eines der schlimmsten Plätze im Internet.
Also, was ist da wichtig, Mainboard?
Was ist da noch wichtig?
Sortiere nach Audi?
Was?
Okay, Toslink wäre schon tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Also, ein Toslink-Ausgang wäre mir wirklich ganz lieb für mein Audiointerface.
Dass ich meinen Rechner gescheit anschließen kann.
Brauchst du überhaupt, brauchst du überhaupt Onboard Audio?
Naja, wäre ganz praktisch anstatt der extra Grafikkarte.
Toslink ist nicht Omega Lul.
Toslink ist für mein Audiointerface echt nicht verkehrt.
Toslink ist ein optischer Audioanschluss.
Du kannst auch einen Adapter hinhängen.
Ach, Quatsch.
Toslink, bocker Tos.
Da bräuchte ich eine extra Soundkarte.
Was soll das Mainboard maximal kosten?
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, nach was soll ich gucken?
ALC? ALC 84 oder ALC 1220?
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen dem ganzen Zeug?
Seriously, ich hab keinen Plan.
Ich weiß, dass das verschiedene Chips von Realtek sind, aber was können die unterschiedlich?
Also ich hab ja aktuell...
Was hab ich denn aktuell für ein Audiochip?
Zeig mal her.
Wo ist das Geizhals...
Signal Noise Ratio.
Also dadurch, dass ich Toslink verwende, ist es eh egal.
Da rauscht nichts, weil es digital übertragen wird als Audiointerface.
Manche haben auch bessere Headphone Preamps.
Ich brauch kein Preamp.
Ich brauch einen optischen Audioausgang.
Ich hab eh alles am Audiointerface hängen.
Deswegen ist es mir eigentlich typisch egal.
Der hat einen ALC 1120.
Und ich weiß noch nicht mal, was das mir genau sagen soll.
Das ist echt mystifiziert.
Ein High Fidelity Mehrkanal Audio Codec mit bilingualer Schnittstelle.
Was?
Was soll uns das sagen?
Cringe, wer das nicht weiß.
High Fidelity?
I2C?
Was zum Teufel hat das damit zu tun?
Warum braucht es I2C Kommunikation?
Was interessiert mich das auch bei einer Soundkarte?
Kann ich da einen Microcontroller anschließen oder was?
Direct Stream Digital.
Ich hab kein Plastenschimmer, was ich überhaupt am Lesen bin.
Okay, letztendlich ist mir es wurscht.
Hauptsache, es hat einen optischen Audioausgang.
Habe ich das Mainboard?
Hier sind wir noch.
Tosslink.
Alles klar.
Was bleibt mir jetzt noch übrig?
Ah, ist das Encoded, dass man sich nicht irgendwelches Rauschen mit einhandelt oder so?
Weil digitale Übertragungen Pfeiffett für Rauschen.
Pfeiffett gegen Rauschen.
Achso, es sollte auch ein, du hast recht, es sollte das richtige Mainboard sein.
Es sollte ein Z900, 700 sind die jetzt, oder?
Z790 sind doch die neuen, glaub.
Okay, da gibt es schon mal nicht viele.
Da gibt es, es gibt also nur 19 Mainboards zur Auswahl.
Das ist doch gut.
Wir haben es doch schon.
Okay, Chat, jetzt weiß ich Bescheid.
Ihr auch?
Ich hoffe, jetzt ist alles klar.
DSD ist eine Alternative zu PCM.
Okay, das weiß ich, das ist PULS, Modulation, PULS, irgendwas.
Wird vorwiegend für SACD, Super Audio CD verwendet.
Obviously.
Natürlich.
Ist auch logisch, ja.
Ah ja, genau.
Okay, hier sind wir in Regionen, die mir ein bisschen zu teuer sind für Mainboards vielleicht.
Hier, SROC, ETX, Wi-Fi, MSI, Tomahawk, das ist doch schon mal ein guter Name.
iChill Fertility Headshot Pro.
Okay, wie viel kostet das?
Tomahawk.
Okay, nur mal so, nur mal, dass ich checke.
Was ist der Unterschied jetzt zwischen zum Beispiel dem und dem?
Hatten die nicht die Möglichkeit, das irgendwie zur Vergleichsliste hinzufügen?
Genau.
Jetzt vergleichen.
Okay.
Der Formfaktor heißt im Endeffekt, das ist Mini-ETX und das ist volles ATX.
Was auch heißt, hier hat man nur ein PCI-Exp...
Oh, das ist viel zu wenig.
Da passt ja nichts mehr rein außer eine Grafikkarte, das fällt schon mal raus.
Das fällt schon mal raus, das ist schon mal nichts.
Da ist schon mal nichts.
Please Dark Mode.
Ich hab den Dark Reader hier deinstalliert, weil ich vermutet habe, das macht Probleme
mit OBS irgendwie.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was hat letztens gerauscht, aber alles, was es sein konnte, entfernt.
Ach, du meinst hier, easy, nice.
Was ist sonst so der Unterschied?
Gut, natürlich mehr PCI-Anschlüsse, das ist klar.
USB-Header, TPS, Thunderbolt-Header.
Virtuelle Phasen, 17 virtuelle Phasen, 9 reale Phasen.
Okay Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung, was mir das sagen sollte.
Absolute 3-Head.
Hat irgendjemand einen Plan, was das bedeuten soll?
Ich weiß, ich mach beruflich was mit Computer, aber ich hab keine Ahnung, was das bedeuten
soll.
Ja, bessere Spannungsversorgung, so schlau bin ich auch.
Die 9 sind gedoppelt.
Und das heißt?
Und für was hat es einen PWM-Controller?
PWM-Controller für was?
Für Lüfter?
Oder für?
Ja, Frequenzgeber für was?
Für Spannungswand?
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Tomahawk.
Okay, hier haben wir schon ein bisschen mehr Anschlüsse.
Wir haben einmal einen fetten, versilberten oder ist das ein Slot aus Metall, dass der
besonders stabil ist für superfette Grafikkarten?
Okay, nice, ich glaub sowas ist nicht verkehrt für eine 4090.
Alle High-End Boards, ja aber ist das ein High-End Board?
Das kostet nur ein Drittel von den teureren.
Schaut ihr mal die Boards aus den beiden Links an.
Ja, 690 will ich nicht mehr.
Asus ROG, ach easy.
Fast Geschenk da.
Alle Varianten, ne ne.
Das beste Z7, ja aber das ist das wo ich sagen würde, das ist übertrieben.
Wozu?
Also ich muss sagen, das finde ich gar nicht mal so übel hier.
Das gefällt mir, das hat, okay wir müssen mal kurz durchgucken was das alles hier am
Stand hat.
Also 4x DDR5, maximal, was soll mir das sagen?
Dual PC5, 54.400 DDR5.
Was?
Aber okay, DDR5 6800, alles klar.
Aha, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid Leute.
Exzellent 6-Head-Time hier wieder.
Ich will mir weder Strebzeug zu kaufen, was outdated ist schon zum Kaufzeitpunkt.
Ich finde, also ehrlich gesagt, ich finde das hier, das ist, das ist, das erscheint mir
ganz super.
Hat das Bluetooth?
Ja.
Brauche ich manchmal.
Ist das hier gut?
Nicht dass es, nicht dass es für mich mit dem Audio irgendwie einen Unterschied macht.
Hat nicht mal Gaming im Titel?
Ja, das hat kein iChill Windforce Fatality Headshot Killer Pro oder so.
Soll das überhaupt funktionieren?
Ab nächstem Jahr, das ist richtig, aber ab Ende nächsten Jahres und dann habe ich das
schon längst gekauft.
So, das sieht doch eigentlich ganz nice aus.
Ist ALC 4080 besser als ALC 1220?
Die Zahlen sagen ja nicht immer zwangsläufig was aus.
Nicht dass es, Hauptsache es hat einen optischen Ausgang für mein Audiointerface, das ist
mir egal.
Wenn du jetzt noch einen neuen Router holst, den neuen, nice, ich brauche noch neue Access
Points.
Wird mal Zeit für brandneue Access Points 1500 Euro das Stück.
Äh, warum sollte ich ein On-Board, ein On-Board plus ein On-Board plus ein On-Board plus ein
USB Interface benutzen?
Das USB Interface ist doch seine eigene Soundkarte, also sprich was hat die On-Board Soundkarte
mit dem USB Interface zu tun?
Also das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Das ist eine eigene Soundkarte und das ist eine eigene Soundkarte.
Was da und das da, sind zwei unterschiedliche Soundkarten.
Letztendlich ist es mir aber egal, ich will dass das digital übertragen wird an mein Audio
Interface und gut ist.
Ne, dass USB für USB ausgelegt ist, das habe ich mir gedacht.
Ansonsten kann ich beides eher, ja.
Deswegen, das ist das wichtigste.
Das finde ich nicht schlecht hier, das ist preislich doch in Ordnung.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren?
Na ok, doch, 370 Euro, man kann sich theoretisch schon beschweren, aber...
Ich hab ne, ich mach ne 10 Gigabit Karte rein.
Also brauchen wir noch fürs Mainboard ungefähr 350 Euro und 370 Euro eher, weil abfuck teuer
alles ist.
Dann sind wir schon bei 3400 Euro.
Das ist was das Zeug kostet man.
Wir haben noch keinen RAM und keine SSD und kein Netzteil und nichts.
Ok, aber das finde ich, also das Mainboard finde ich eigentlich ganz nice, das gefällt
mir.
Wegen RAM nochmal, ok.
Portal durch DDR5 in Spielen.
Reptilex Setup wirkt darüber hinaus nicht auf, sondern darf 5000 Second nutzen.
Der Leistungszugewinn beträgt einem ebenfalls nur 3%.
Ja, am Moment, das ist der Unterschied zwischen RAM-Takt und nicht zwischen DDR4 versus...
DDR5, oder?
Das ist DDR5 4008 mit DDR5, was?
Nur der RAM-Takt.
So, na gut.
Liste leeren.
Die RGB-Spezifikation bei Videozahler.
Weiß nicht, ob der irgendwas mit RGB hat.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Headerbeleuchtung, RGB, 3x3 Pin, RGB.
Ohne RGB geht ja heute nichts mehr.
Also was?
Der kann bis zu 6800.
Das ist zu krass teuer, 6800.
Also da bin ich mir relativ...
Das ist unsinnig.
Ich bin blöd, ich hab den Arbeitsspeicher schon zugemacht.
DDR5?
Speichertakt ab.
Lieber 5600 kaufen.
5600.
Was sind gute Timings, Leute?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Was haben die hier denn drinnen?
Timings, steht gar nichts.
CL36?
Okay, also das ist Crap, sagt ihr dann.
Hier, CL36.
Was kosten hier die RGB-Dinger nochmal, die ich eben hatte?
36, 36, 89?
Äh, warum ist das teurer?
Ach nee, weil es weniger RAM ist und pro Gigabyte ist teurer, okay.
Was ist denn die letzte Zahl da hinten?
Auf was bezieht sich die?
Wie ich da keine Ahnung von hab.
Ich weiß, dass es Timings sind, das sind alles Timings, wie willst du wissen, was die letzte Zahl von den Timings ist?
Terras, also.
Exis auf... Nee, ach was weiß ich.
Was ist Terras?
Die der Speicherwartungssystem einen Befehl ausgewirrt hat.
Nur die ersten beiden wichtig, okay.
Gibt es hier so wahnsinnig viele... Guck mal, das ist doch genau das gleiche, oder?
Also DDR4, 36.
36.
Okay, das sind 32G.
Das sind vier?
Ich verstehe denn warum das... Ach, das sind alles 32er hier, die teurer sind.
CL... Oh, CL30, jetzt war...
Uiuiui.
Also 30 ist wahrscheinlich übertrieben Hardcore-Ramen dann schon, oder?
So ganz leuchtet mir die... Ach, so gut, weil es wieder 64G ist.
Kann man sortieren... Okay, Moment mal, wir machen das mal anders, wir machen jetzt Sixhead.
Wobei, eigentlich bin ich doch bescheuert.
Das ist...
Ich mein, eigentlich ist das doch vollkommen in Ordnung, oder?
Eigentlich ist das doch vollkommen... Geht das doch voll klar, oder?
Was? Moment, Moment, was?
Willst du halt Hynix M die IC-Chips auf den RAM-Ring? Will ich das? Warum?
Ich will überhaupt nichts tunen.
Das soll standardmäßig einfach mit dem... Ich will nichts übertakten oder so.
Das soll einfach mit dem laufen, was ich gekauft habe und gut ist.
Übertakt ist immer... Ja, aber das ist eingebaut und das ist mir egal.
Das ist kompatibel mit dem Mainboard, das passt.
Also irgendwie so war es hier in der Richtung... Ah, sagen wir mal, ungefähr 400€ muss noch mal oben drauf für RAM. Ohne mich jetzt exakt hier auf das jeweilige Fest zu legen.
Ach, das ist ja schon DDR5 6000.
Ich mein 32G reichen eigentlich auch, ja.
Komm, sagen wir mal ungefähr 400€ ungefähr ungefähr ungefähr 400€ der RAM. So, gut.
So, das nächste wird easy. Also Netzteil brauchen wir auch noch.
Das nächste wird easy, irgendeine Samsung SSD.
Solid State.
Gibt es eigentlich schon... Oh nein, ich habe es falsch ausgewählt. Ich will NVMe haben.
Oh, wat?
Was wollen die von mir?
Gibt es schon 4TB?
Das ist wahrscheinlich unsinnig teuer, oder?
Das bringt nichts.
Ich glaube 2TB ist immer noch das beste preisleistungstechnisch auch bei NVMe SSDs.
Von Größe zu...
Ok, preisleistungsmäßig vielleicht nicht von Gigabyte zu Euro, aber von dem was man an Größe haben will und wo man mit gut klar kommt.
Ich nehme mir ab.
QLC Speicher, sucked.
Ja, crucial.
Kann man damit irgendeine Samsung mal gucken.
Ich hatte den letzten drei Rechner in der Samsung SSD, das war eigentlich ganz ok.
Hier 970 EVO Plus, ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung, kann man nehmen. Also ungefähr 200€ nochmal für die SSD dabei, fertig.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen einer Samsung SSD 89 Pro und einer EVO?
Hat die noch mal krasseren 5Head Speicher? Ah nein, die ist schneller.
Oh, die brauchen einen Kühlkörper. Die ist so schnell. Aber Kühlkörper ist doch auf dem Mainboard schon drauf, oder?
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich vermutet, dass hier die SSD drunter kommt.
Übrigens wisst ihr was, das Mainboard sieht aus wie schlecht 3D gedruckt.
Findet ihr den hier auch? Diese Dinger hier sehen ein bisschen aus wie aus dem schlechten 3D Drucker.
Was denn das?
Ist das ein Onboard-USB-Port?
Ach, der Front-Header für USB. Achso.
Ok Leute, warum sieht denn der ATX-Stecker so komisch aus? Sehen die jetzt immer so aus?
Ist das überhaupt der ATX-Stecker? Warum sehen die so komisch aus?
Ich kenne nur ATX-Stecker, die so ein...
Das ist CPU-Power.
Und wo kommt das Netzteil dann dran?
Wo?
Ach da! Ah ja, ah. Aber man müsste auch genau hingucken. Lul.
Ok.
Ja, der sieht so aus wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Das ist noch mal extra CPU-Power? Ah.
2x 8-Pin-CPU-Power und dann brauche ich noch 2x 8-Pin-Grafikkarten-Power?
Haut aber rein, ne?
Also sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal SSD kostet ungefähr noch mal 230 Euro oder so in dem Dreh, irgendwie 220.
Netzteil habe ich noch eins, aber das ist eigentlich zu klein dimensioniert.
Ich muss mal kurz auf dem...
Auf dem Handy gucken.
Seasonic.
Netzteil.
Habe ich noch.
Ja.
Das ist nur ein 600 Watt Netzteil. Das wird dafür nicht reichen.
Aber das ist immerhin ein Titanium 8 600 Watt. Aber das bringt mir nichts.
Was ist denn da überhaupt sinnvolle für Netzteile? Was muss denn das da überhaupt sein?
Ich meine, 600 ist zu wenig, 1000 oder tut es wenig?
Pequiet hat ein Calculator. Pequiet Netzteile hatte ich auch schon ein paar, ja.
Aber erstmal noch ein paar Latex-Handschuhe kaufen, easy.
Wir können bei Hardware-Rat gucken.
Was die am Start haben.
Gaming-PCs sortieren nach höchster Preis. Natürlich, natürlich höchster Preis.
Hier, da, guck mal. Gaming-PC Intel 4300.
Naja, so ungefähr kommt das Preisliche auch hin, was ich mir da jetzt überlegt habe, ja.
Presq. Nur weil ein Netzteil in der Spitze 1000 Watt liefern kann, heißt das nicht, dass ein 1000 Watt Netzteil immer 1000 Watt dann auch verbrät.
Insofern, Idle braucht das Ding wahrscheinlich nach wie vor so gut wie nichts.
Gut, der Wirkungsgrad bei Idle ist halt bei einem 1000 Watt Netzteil noch schlechter als bei einem anderen.
Was ist denn da drinnen?
Der RTX. Naja, von der Konfig ist es ziemlich ähnlich. Ist es ziemlich ähnlich zu dem, was ich jetzt auch zusammenbauen würde, oder?
Wasserkühlung. 420 mm Arctic Liquid Freezer.
Alles klar. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Wasserkühlung, aber eigentlich will ich lieber selbst bauen.
Aber nur 5600 CL40. Ja, nur. Wie soll man das nur benutzen? Guck mal, da hat es gleiche Mainboard.
Guck mal, da hat es gleiche Mainboard. Da haben wir uns schon mal was ganz Gutes rausgesucht.
Unusable. PS, FSP. Ist FSP nicht so ein billiger China-Chinesen-Hersteller?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander mit? Nee, nee, sorry. Was ich meine ist LC Power. LC Power ist billiger China-Chinesen-Hersteller.
LC Power ist das Ding, was abbraucht immer.
Silencium PC SG7 VGT.
Gibt es nicht mehr. Okay, nice.
Ich will mein Fractal Design Gehäuse haben.
Gehäuse steht da übrigens auch noch nicht drauf. WTF. Und was kostet so eine Wasserkühlung?
Arctic Liquid Freezer. 140? Echt? Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, das ist teurer.
Das geht doch voll klar. 140 Euro.
Das geht doch voll klar.
140 Euro. Das Gehäuse hat glaube ich auch 240 gekostet. Und das Netzteil, was kostet? Gucken wir mal hier, Netzteil.
Die sind lauter als Luftkühlung. Mal gucken.
Drehen die sich im Eidelbetrieb auch runter oder laufen die immer mit exakt demgleichen?
Das geht doch bestimmt nach Wassertemperatur oder? Wie schnell der Radiator dreht.
Pumpe läuft immer.
Snowbeer. Ich hole mir wahrscheinlich ein OLED Display dann irgendwann demnächst.
Mal kurz gucken.
Quiet. Die Finger sind immer.
So.
Ab.
Okay, Netzteil brauchen wir dann auch noch mal 140 Euro.
Das wird teuer, Leute. Das wird teuer.
Jetzt habe ich alles, oder?
Also.
Oh, ich habe mal gerechnet. Das ist vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen übertrieben. So teuer ist es dann doch nicht.
Los, los, los, los, alter.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
1500 Euro.
Snowbeer, keine Ahnung. Ja, gibt es, aber ich kann dir gerade keine empfehlen.
Die SSD solltest du auch noch wechseln. Na ja, die andere kostet ungefähr das gleiche. Die 40 Euro machen es dir jetzt nicht aus.
Das ist schon.
Nicht ohne.
Dann wird halt dieses Jahr mal ein bisschen was ausgegeben. Erst neues Auto gekauft von ein paar Monaten.
So lange ist noch gar nicht her. Zwei Monate oder so. Jetzt noch ein neuer Rechner, ein neuer Bildschirm. Das wird teuer dieses Jahr.
Warte noch auf Black Friday. Stimmt ist ja demnächst irgendwann.
Wobei ich blicke da mittlerweile gar nicht mehr durch. Black Friday Cyber Monday. Cyber Monday Week.
Manche Läden habe ich jetzt schon gelesen. Cyber Monday Monat.
Da hast du ja quasi das halbe Jahr über irgendwelche Angebote.
Bald gibt es gibt es wahrscheinlich das Cyber Monday Jahr.
Dann ist das komplette Jahr Cyber Monday.
Nehm Kredit auf. Nee, nee, so schlimm ist das denn. Ich kann mir das schon leisten. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob ich das will.
Was macht der Windows Rechner da für Dinger?
Wenn man einfach Enter drückt.
Prozent bei Alternate.
Da muss man aber auch genau das bekommen im Angebot, was man sucht.
Das ist schon verdammt wie Kohle jetzt für neuen Rechner.
Ich glaube, ich bestelle mir so ein Teil.
Easy. Komm, Leute, das ist für fünf Jahre wieder Ruhe. Scheiß doch drauf.
Das ist für fünf Jahre Ruhe. Ich muss jetzt nur. Okay, offene Fragen sind nach wie vor.
Die da wirklich? Welches Gehäuse exakt? Welches Netzteil exakt?
Welcher RAM exakt?
Bin ich auch noch nicht ganz sicher. Also da variiert es noch ein bisschen.
Aber die Base ist eigentlich relativ klar.
Ich muss mir das mal dahinter schreiben, sonst finde ich das nämlich morgen nicht mehr.
Was es für ein Mainboard war.
Wurde schon erklärt, warum kein Reisen? Nee, wurde nicht erklärt.
Ich habe mir vor ein paar Wochen eins zusammengestellt.
Da wollte ich noch was mit Reisen kaufen.
Aber leistungstechnisch finde ich tatsächlich jetzt die neue Intel Kiste besser.
Aber natürlich frisst das Ding in der Spitze ordentlich Strom.
4500 Euro auf fünf Jahre sind 75 Euro pro Monat.
5 mal 12 sind 60. Also im Prinzip müssen wir einfach nur gucken, ob das stimmt.
75 mal 60 rechnen. Ja, exzellent. Quickmaps Leute.
Ja, 75 Euro im Monat.
Weil Beste haben wollen.
Die wird vielleicht ähnlich sein, aber bestimmt nicht schneller.
Ohne 4080 ist mir ist nichts.
Ich will also, wenn es eine 4090 Ti geben würde, dann könnte man sich das überlegen.
Was hast du für ein Audio Interface? Ich habe einen Moto Track 16.
Das ist schon ein bisschen älter.
Habe ich mir vor ein paar Jahren gekauft, aber das ist wirklich nice.
Das hat mehr Ausgänge als man hier sieht. Das hat noch so einen Adapter.
Ja, guck mal, du hast hier noch einen Adapter.
Die Fotos sind ziemlich die unglücklichsten Fotos, die man davon machen kann.
Also die Fotos sind richtig dumm. Man sieht überhaupt nicht die Anschlüsse da dran.
Ah, jetzt doch. Okay. Ja, also du hast vorne, hast du Anschlüsse für, hast du zwei Kopfhöreranschlüsse.
Theoretisch kannst du noch einen innen. Da habe ich jetzt beispielsweise gerade, was habe ich da dran?
Ich glaube den Mix Amp von der Konsole habe ich da dran.
Du kannst eine Gitarre anschließen, nicht da ich das wirklich bräuchte.
Was ganz praktisch ist, du hast halt hier dieses Breakout Kabel und Tosslink Eingang.
Du hast hinten, das ist total hängen geblieben, die Seite.
Du hast hinten einen digitalen Eingang. Du hast hier dieses Breakout Kabel.
Da hast du dann XLR für den Mikrofon dran. Noch ein paar Line-Ins und Outputs und alles.
Firewire. Lull.
Also das Ding habe ich schon seit ein paar Jahren. Ich muss sagen, es war eine super Idee mir damals das zu kaufen.
Weil seitdem habe ich auch keine Probleme mehr, dass ich irgendwie Audio von einer Quelle oder so nicht richtig hin bekomme.
Also es ist jetzt egal, ob ich die Konsole anmache, ob ich den zweiten PC habe, meinen Haupt-PC, irgendwie das Headset.
Ich höre das einfach alles auf dem Kopfhörer.
Also und kann sogar mit dem Knopf noch ein bisschen abmischen dazwischen.
Könnte theoretisch mit Knopfdreh umschalten, auch noch auf die Lautsprecher.
Also das ist tatsächlich eine gute Sache.
Na dann, erzähl doch mal. Was ist denn so schlecht an der Zusammenstellung?
Das finde ich immer geil, diese Comments.
Ich meine zumal die Zusammenstellung noch überhaupt nicht aussagekräftig ist, weil weder fest steht was für ein Gehäuse,
noch was für ein RAM, noch was für ein Netzteil, noch was für eine Kühlung genau.
Ich meine eigentlich kann man diese Zusammenstellung jetzt eigentlich gar nicht.
Verkehrt sein, ich meine das einzige, worauf ich mich wirklich festgelegt habe, ist das Mainboard.
Kann man zwei Kopfhörer anschließen? Ja, kannst du, kannst zwei Kopfhörer.
Kannst du gar noch mehr anschließen? Kannst hier unten.
Okay, nicht wirklich, wenn du ohne Adapter, aber geht auch. Kannst beispielsweise hier noch anschließen.
Also ich habe zwei Kopfhörer dran aktuell. Hier dran.
Ah ja, das habe ich mir noch gerade schon angeguckt.
Das habe ich mir noch schon angeguckt.
Da guck, da ist es.
Zu wenig RGB.
Noch kein RGB. Guck mal, mein Gehäuse sieht schon aus wie irgendwie ein Heizlüfter.
Und das Mainboard ist überteuert. Ich habe vor etlichen Minuten gleich erläutert, warum ein Z.
Ich habe das nicht überlesen. Ich will mir aber nichts kaufen, was jetzt schon outdated ist.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass die Z690 preisleistungstechnisch besser sind.
Aber mir wieder strebt es immer was zu kaufen, was eigentlich schon nicht mehr aktuell ist.
Und so überteuert ist das noch gar nicht, weil mein Hardware Rat das verbaut, der wirklich den Kram auch ein Jahr...
Was ist denn das für ein Argument? Ich kaufe das aber jetzt und nicht in einem Jahr.
Ich will jetzt nichts kaufen, was jetzt schon outdated ist. Ob das in einem Jahr outdated ist, was juckt es mich denn?
Was interessiert es mir in einem Jahr? In einem Jahr gibt es auch eine neue CPU und vielleicht eine 4090 Ti oder sonst was.
Es ist doch vollkommen egal, was in einem Jahr ist.
Und außerdem, wenn es so rum ist, könntest du ja quasi immer warten, bis du dir was Neues kaufst.
Irgendwann musst du mal was Neues kaufen. Also musst du jetzt. Musst du nicht?
Eigentlich könnte ich meinen Rechner noch weiterverwenden.
Aus welchem Jahr? 2017. Mit einem kleinen RAM Upgrade zwischendurch. Ein paar mehr SSDs drin.
Ich habe aktuell 8700K und 1080 Ti. Geht eigentlich noch komplett klar, aber so langsam muss es mal sein.
Minus aus 2015.
Ich habe nur einen 1080p Bildschirm. Deswegen. Geht doch voll klar. Ich habe einen 1080p 240Hz Bildschirm.
Ich meine, ich erreiche bei neueren Games mit gescheiten Details keine 240 FPS.
Außer in MW2, da erreiche ich noch nicht mal auf ultra-low 240 FPS. Ja, mache ich auch.
Ich wollte mir einen neuen Monitor holen, aber erstmal hole ich mir einen neuen Rechner.
Ich kann den nicht verlosen, den verwende ich dann zur Streamvorschau.
Ich kaufe mir erstmal einen neuen Rechner und dann kaufe ich mir einen neuen Monitor.
Da muss ich nämlich auch noch mal gucken. Wahrscheinlich irgendeine OLED-Kiste.
Welche 4090 wird es denn? Ist noch nicht ganz klar. Irgendwas, was lieferbar ist zu dem Zeitpunkt, wenn ich es dann bestelle.
1080Ti für die Streamvorschau. Ah ja, was willst du machen?
Ich könnte sie rausschrauben und die Onboard-GPU verwenden, bis sie weniger Strom verbraucht.
Aber eine macht jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel Unterschied.
1080 SLE. Ich glaube, SLE ist komplett out. SLE macht glaube ich keiner mehr.
Ich glaube, es gibt noch nicht mal mehr SLE-Brücken mittlerweile an den Grafikkarten.
SLE ist dead.
Warum keine von AMD? Weil es die ganz neuen von AMD noch nicht gibt.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass die schneller sind als von Nvidia. Ähnlich vielleicht, aber nicht schneller.
Vielleicht ist es ja so, wie gesagt, ich bestelle mir das erst in ein paar Wochen.
Vielleicht gibt es sie ja bis dahin dann. Und sollten sie konkurrenzfähig sein, denke ich dann natürlich mal drüber nach.
Also sollten die bloß irgendwie 5% langsamer sein und die Hälfte kosten.
Dann kann man sich das überlegen. Aber ansonsten, ich denke, ich fahre da mit einer 4090 ganz gut.
Ist halt teuer als Fakt, wenn man sich überlegt, dass es quasi das Doppelte kostet.
Ja, ungefähr das Doppelte von früheren High-End-Modellen. Ist schon heftig.
Woher weißt du das jetzt schon? Das Ding ist doch noch gar nicht raus.
Und ich glaube richtige Benchmarks gibt es auch noch nicht.
Sind sie jetzt einfach so mal ins Blaue geraten oder?
Okay, ja, gibt viele Gerüchte.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die 4090 jetzt nicht das ist, was sich der 0815-PC-Gamer überhaupt kauft.
Es ist bestimmt schlauer von AMD sogar mit einer 4080 zu konkurrieren.
Also das Video habe ich gesehen.
Bei dem Video kam raus, dass es ungefähr gleich schnell, ungefähr ein bisschen langsamer als eine 4090 ist,
wenn man laut eigenen AMD-Zahlen geht und die hochrechnet. Aber das ist halt nur sehr, sehr, sehr vage.
Was ist jetzt mit Gehäuse? Ich weiß es noch nicht genau.
Also das fand ich cool.
Das fand ich sehr schick.
Das Teil.
Und das Wichtigste für mich, ein Staubfilter hat es auch, oder?
Staubfilter, ohne Staubfilter kommt mir nichts mehr ins Haus.
Wenn du noch auf Black Friday, was ist denn Black Friday?
25. November und wann ist Cyber Monday?
28. November, alles klar. Das ist also direkt dahinter der.
Und ist dann Black Friday Weekend oder so bei Amazon und Black Friday Week davor wieder
und Cyber Monday Monat, dann die übertreiben es ja komplett mit dem Kram.
Was?
54 Prozent Improvement.
Kann man das jetzt nicht angucken?
So lange.
Ich muss mal kurz den Sound ein bisschen lauter machen.
Hat er sich aber geschickt rausgeredet, warum man keinen Vergleich macht.
Okay, man weiß, dass man nichts weiß. Auch gut.
Wie ich das unterstützen kann?
Naja, indem ich die Kohle habe, dass ich mir das kaufen kann und ich die schnellste Grafiker
ich will ganz einfach.
Und sollte AMD wirklich mal wieder konkurrenzfähig sein, was Grafikkarten angeht,
dann wird das wahrscheinlich für alle Vorteile haben.
Also wenn die Nvidia tatsächlich im wichtigen Segment da ordentlich was abknapsen, dann werden die wieder billiger.
Das wird dann für alle gut sein.
Also wir können eigentlich alle nur hoffen, dass AMD gute Grafikkarten rausbringt.
Auch langfristig, was das angeht.
Also eigentlich müsste man hoffen, dass AMD richtig abgeht, was Grafikkarten angeht.
Dass der Kram wieder ein bisschen billiger wird.
Ja doch, mein PC ist sichtbar, aber es ist nicht so, als geht mir da einer drauf ab.
Der steht halt einfach da und gut ist.
Also ich habe hier beispielsweise auch einen mit Scheibe nebendrin gehabt, da habe ich nie reingeguckt.
Hat halt einfach eine Scheibe, so gut.
Easy Scheibe.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Okay Leute, ich glaube, jetzt habe ich genug geguckt.
Jetzt weiß ich schon mal ein bisschen mehr Bescheid.
Das muss noch geklärt werden, aber ich habe hier noch zwei, drei Wochen Zeit.
Eventuell, da steht nicht auf dem Schreibtisch, da steht neben auf dem Schreibtisch.
Eventuell gibt es dann auch gar nichts mehr, ist nicht mehr lieferbar.
Ja, es ist schon nicht so schlimm.
Der dicke Michi.
Gibt Schlimmeres.
Ich bin noch wach, aber nicht mal lange.
Ich gehe jetzt ins Bett, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
CU, Bedgetime.
Morgen früh wieder.
Irgendwie neun Uhr oder so.
Bis denn.